boy what a big day this is for 30 year
old chris mazza making his first ever
major league start
born in walnut creek california in 1989
the day the earthquake interrupted the
a's giants world series
his grandmother is cousins of joe
dimaggio
of all the twists in a red sox yankees
game
here is a geo ushella he's a right-hand
hitter
and this line of left field has a base
hit verdugo cuts it off toward the line
and will hold
geo to a single on a hard headline drive
a shella is now 18 for 64
with four homers and 15 rbis here's
glebe torres
memory here's the pitch and he swings
and misses though he came back with a
high fastball up and away that might
have been ball four
but he got himself out chasing it over
anxious was torrez and her our two men
down for mike ford who's at 156 with the
homer seven rbis left-hand batting first
baseman here's mike ford now following a
strike to ford
that one sent out to shallow right
center field it drops in
it's going to bring in arcelo to score
the game's first run one-nothing yankees
but watch him fight it staying inside
the baseball not trying to do too much
nice hitting here by ford and the
yankees good matchup here for chasers
likes to bury the pitch down that's
exactly where chavis likes it here's the
3-2
to shavus
half-swing and a fastball up he struck
him out
he made shavus chase
no runs one hit one left and you've been
ending in a half it's one nothing yanks
here's aaron hicks slide the left his
first time up
swung on and grounded and hit the bag
first goes into right field is going to
get a base hit for a run gardner scores
on his way to second is hicks oh did the
yankees get a break that's just a ground
ball at the first and it struck the bag
and kangarooed over the head of chavis
so it's a ribby double for hicks and the
yankees take a two-nothing lead yeah and
hicks knew that and there's nothing
chavez can can do about that boy if this
team didn't have bad luck they wouldn't
have any luck at all lahr walked leading
off the game red sox fed just two base
runners pilar turns on a ball and sends
it into the left field corner and that
one is gone
kevin pallar with a home run just fair
down the left field line his second
homer of the season his ninth run batted
in
381 feet the tail of the tape and the
red sox are on the board now down two to
one ford had a ribby single his first
time up the 2-0
swung on and hit in the air to deep
right that ball is high it is far it is
gone
mike ford it's a two-run home run deep
to right
there's a ford in the yankees future
mike is four and tough he hits a two run
jack to deep right center and the
yankees take a 4-1 lead you know you
don't like to say that that he's a
mistake hitter because he's not but if
he gets a mistake it leaves the park
now here is christian vasquez the
righty-hitting catcher d-h today he hits
a ground ball at the third ashela to
wade one on the first double play of
five four three
i'd be amazed if they took that happy
needs one more innings to try to get the
win and he's pitched very well
so be a 2-2 from
swingline drive nice backhand stop by
bogarts and he throws to first in time
to get the speedy weighed by a step on a
bang bang play bogarts was playing right
behind the second base bag and was
perfectly positioned it was a smash
that landed just to the right of bogarts
and he played it on a short hop went
down to a knee got up good stretch by
chavis here is alex verdugo to lead it
off verdugo picks up a hitting streak in
his first chance
stands at seven and counting now tough
play for happ and he gets there just a
step ahead of verdugo hap leaves on a
very high note five and two thirds to
this point one run one run three hits
three strikeouts two walks his best
outing of the year by far he'll chew
down and here's glaibo torres gleber is
two for three on the night picks off
first with two gone
razors three one and he loses torres the
second walk of the inning so it's an
error charge to the rookie second
baseman keeps the ending alive and loads
the bases for gary sanchez who hit a
tape measure homer against brazier on
friday night and the pitch is strike
three call to fastball at the knees
sanchez
called out on strikes and after all that
the yankees do not score
the yankees are one out away
and a little dribbling ball up the first
baseline britain feels and loses the
ball
as he tag peraza goes to right field the
run scores vasquez scores and the game
continues players kevin plowecki and he
is the tying run is it 2-2
struck him out swinging ball game over
yankees win the
yankees
win